[Musik]
die Deutschen wissen nicht wie man reich
wird aber das wird sich bestimmt bald
ändern mit einer neuen Plattform des
Finanzministers höchstpersönlich ich
habe eigentlich nur eine Frage wie werde
ich denn jetzt reich
äh reich werden sie zuallererst mal in
dem sich erlauben Reich zu sich Reich zu
fühlen theoretisch
also ich will Cola haben das nützt mir
denn das Gefühl dass ich reich bin ich
will die ich will es in meinem
Geldbeutel haben haben sie einen
Sparplan immer wie sieht der aus
monatlich etwas zur Seite legen wenn ich
jetzt nichts habe dann müssen sich einen
anderen Job suchen ach ach wirklich
sparen könnten sind sie der Beweis dafür
dass es jeder schaffen kann zumindest
wenn er in der FDP ist
jeder schaffen ja klar hat mir nie
jemand gesagt dass ich mal Ministerin
werde sie können vielleicht auch noch
schaffen aber schaffen es auch die 14
Millionen Deutsche in Armut leben die ja
nichts investieren können es geht ja
darum dass man
wenn man früh
angeht und zu wissen was passiert darum
geht es
investieren und sparen das sollen unsere
Lieblingsbeschäftigung werden also dann
hält uns ja nichts mehr auf oder
wir wissen das so die untere Hälfte auf
der einkommenskala gar nichts hat die
die
Leben von der Hand nimmt oder machen
Schulden und den jetzt sprach oder
Anlagetipps zu geben ist natürlich der
gleiche als gebe ich nun verhungernden
Kochbuch also für mich so richtig weit
das heißt um etwas zu investieren
bräuchten die erstmal was zum
Investieren den Armut hilft Geld Herr
Linda was würden Sie jemandem raten mit
Rekordschulden zum Beispiel einem
Finanzminister
wenn kein Anlageberater aber der
Finanzminister der hält die
Schuldenbremse jetzt ja ein andere in
ihrem Alter sind ja schon Multimillionär
wo sind sie falsch abgebogen
ach wissen Sie das Wichtigste im Leben
sind Familie Freunde Gesundheit Freiheit
und da kann ich mich nicht beschweren
das haben sie alle wow
meine Eltern haben tatsächlich komplett
versagt was finanzielle Bildung bei mir
angeht und die Scheiße ist ja auch über
die Hälfte des deutschen Vermögens wird
ja vererbt die haben nicht mal Kohle das
heißt das einzige was mir bleibt am Ende
ist die James Last Plattensammlung von
meinem Vater und die Sammelteller von
meiner Mutter ja vielen Dank liebe
Eltern
nein
alles muss man selber machen dann
schreibe ich mal lieber mit wenn der
Finanzminister Predigt deshalb lassen
wie ich glaube Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland einfach Chancen liegen haben
eine nicht so gut aufgestellt hatte
Altersversorgung lassen sich irgendwie
abziehen beim Handyvertrag was haben Sie
denn heute gelernt
ich habe heute gelernt dass die
vulnerapapiergruppen nicht wirklich
Thema sind sondern ist die Frage ob man
sein Haus am Starnberger See kauft oder
ETFs aber nicht dass man sich überhaupt
gar keine
Rente leisten kann oder zusatzversorge
weil man sowieso Grundsicherung kriegt
am Ende und jetzt will ich mein
erworbenes Wissen weitergeben an die die
es betrifft Deutschlands Jugend ihr
müsst nur investieren investieren
investieren wie viel ETFs hast du schon
ich habe gar keine leider aber der
Freund ja wie viel ETF drei vielleicht
gut das bin ich überrascht
ist gut Leute die Jugend die denkt an
die Zukunft
ich arbeite für die Zukunft ich werde
Millionär ja irgendwann ja irgendwann
bin ich so ruhig dann
habe ich keine Probleme mehr es ist top
wie wirst du Millionär das wird mir
interessieren das werde ich noch schauen
sind sie zu dumm um reich zu sein
gute Frage
nein bin ich nicht sind sie reich nein
keine weiteren Fragen
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen